it was 25 Grand wanted to join this
Mastermind so it was literally all of my
money I didn't even ask if there was a
payment plan I just wired the whole
thing and it was among the best
decisions I've ever made in my life and
I actually didn't learn anything
specific from The Mastermind but what I
did learn is all of these other people
they're not smarter than I am like
they're not working harder than I am
like I'm definitely willing to sacrifice
more than these people are I'm
definitely willing to work weekends when
they're not the biggest gift I got from
that was context it was perspective and
so what happened is I was able to
massively decrease my time to getting
places because I was able to use their
time and their experience to sift
through the world of information to say
all you need to follow for media buying
is this guy this is the best book I had
on this thing just read the first half
what I was able to do was get these
shortcuts in all these little chunks on
this bridge of where I wanted to go I
really walked the walk and going all in
on putting the money that I had into me